if you are consistently chasing your
passion project but there's no income
coming in then it's not going to last
very long I wasn't passionate about
helping moms keep their teens safe on
Snapchat it was just something that I
was good at and I recognized there was a
gap in the market that I could fill and
now I've grown and I've built these
other passions when I can make Vlogs of
myself snowboarding even though I know
that those are going to be the absolute
worst performing videos on my YouTube
channel it'll get 200 views but I'm
fired up about it and I'm only able to
do that because I embrace the suck and I
embraced hey I might not love doing this
but I'm good at it and there's a market
for it